hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
political journalists at the financial
times jasmine cameron chaleshi and
assistant comment editor at the
telegraph olivia utley they'll be with
us from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages now the closure of some
petrol stations because of a shortage of
tanker drivers is the top story in the
eye which says fuel rationing could be
on the way
the telegraph says the situation is
causing alarm and raises the specter of
panic buying by motorists
that's also the main story in the
guardian
while the mail says the country is
running on empty
as does the sun
but the times says downing street's
message is one of don't panic
the metro leads with the arrest of a man
in connection with the murder of sabine
and nessa and pictures of another man
police want to trace
the financial times goes with the bank
of england's forecast that inflation
could hit 4 percent or higher next year
by next year although it is holding
interest rates unchanged at the moment
while the star brings us news that one
farm is offering 30 pounds an hour for
people to pick its cabbages apparently
because it can't get enough pickers from
abroad
and we're joined tonight by jasmine
cameron chileshi and olivia utley
evening to both of you thank you very
much for being with us
so we're going to start with the latest
on supply chain issues at the front of
the eye jasmine
fuel being rationed at some petrol
stations bpso and tesco affected so far
so essentially some of um some of these
companies have warned that there could
be potential fuel shortages um so it's
basically been caused by a shortage of
drivers um now this has been a problem
that's been looming for a long time
there were fit there were concerns that
post brexit we'd see a shortage of
drivers but really within the last you
know a couple of weeks couple of months
and over the summer period we're really
seeing this you know the impacts of the
shortage of drivers and i think it's
important to stress of all these stories
that yes the headlines look particularly
alarming um you know there's fears of
shortages of food or fuel but actually
um you know we haven't got to a
situation where there's widespread
shortages at the moment but a lot of
these companies are warning that
potentially there is a crisis looming
and i think this is a situation that the
government really needs to get to grips
with and communicate you know an
atmosphere of calm to the public because
it's certainly not you know reassuring
to be looking at some of these headlines
and thinking oh my goodness will i be
able to get petra will i be able to get
food so i do think it's something that
the government is really gonna need to
control the narrative on in the coming
days yeah when you see the words like
fuel rationed when you hear that petrol
stations are being closed it does
potentially lead to panic olivia doesn't
it the government's messages don't do
anything differently buy your fuel as
normal but how concerned do you think
downing street are about this situation
i think the problem is that sort of
taken on its own it's true that this
fuel crisis doesn't yet at least seem to
be a crisis there are a few garages
which have had to close um but the down
on the street message which i'm sure is
is true and accurate is that is that
there is enough fuel in the uk we're not
facing a
a shortage you might have to drive a
little bit further that's all the
problem is that sort of taken against
the backdrop of everything else that
we've got going on obviously the
furlough scheme is winding up in the
next couple of weeks um we've seen the
price of wholesale gas you know saw
recently which is putting up energy
prices for ordinary people then you've
got the national insurance hike a
problem with the government zone making
which is really going to hit people's
wallets very hard and there's this whole
problem which feels like it's emerging
of a of a winter of discontent and on
top of that having
there's you might not be able to get
fuel in your car when you're driving uh
it it does it does feel a little bit
panicky it does feel a bit back to the
70s vibe
yeah that the telegraph is talking of
that winter of discontent at looming uh
jasmine energy companies going bust
shortages on supermarket shelves in the
run-up to christmas and of course
the uh petrol stations having to close
down
what can be done about it how can people
be reassured what does the government
need to do now
i mean i think there are you know
multiple angles to really tackle this
crisis
and i think you know for one i think
there needs to be public messaging it's
been quite a difficult week on this
front because obviously johnson's been
away in new york and he's been trying to
push the climate agenda meanwhile his
ministers back at home are trying to
reassure people that there's going to be
enough food and fuel so i think
certainly getting the messaging right in
terms of you know increasing the number
of drivers i do think more can be done
from the government in that area so
they've said that they're extending the
hours that drivers can be on the roads
they're extending um you know test
testing for drivers so we can get more
drivers trained up but you know there is
more that can be done to make that
sector more lucrative in terms of you
know offering higher wages offering you
know incentive packages to get people to
join that sector so we're tackling that
issue and i do think you know we do need
to be looking at um obviously the
government has got its net zero um goals
and and that is important but in the
meantime as we're sort of making that
transition to renewables we need to be
looking at our current energy supplies
and recognizing that yes we are still
reliant on things like gas and we need
to make sure that in the meantime we've
got good we've got good supplies that
we're not in this situation again
yeah um let's have a look then olivia at
the guardian again that story leading on
the front of the guardian warning of
fuel shortages amid supply chain crisis
the lorry driver situation situation
and
the prime minister's spokesperson saying
trying to reassure saying there's no
shortage of fuel we have a very
resilient and robust supply chain olivia
but it doesn't seem very robust when you
look at the situation we're in right now
it doesn't seem very robust at all and
we have heard this before about the uk
supply chain um you know a couple of
weeks ago we had to fire up a coal
station again because it turned out that
our wind supply wasn't nearly good
enough there was a time a couple of
weeks ago where
wind farms which are supposed to provide
20 of the uk energy was only providing
three percent of the uk energy so we do
have quite a lot of big supply chain
issues and i agree with jasmine that
quite a lot of the problem is that
the government's been quite idealistic
about uh the net zero targets which you
know very admirable but the government's
been quite idealistic and said this is
these the renewables that we'll be using
to generate our energy and when they
don't really work there doesn't seem to
be a plan b we're very very reliant on
energy from europe we're relying on
energy from russia and that's put us in
a very precarious position and puts us
at the mercy of lots of other countries
which isn't great so i think there needs
to be some serious thinking in it and
it's not a short-term solution at all
but there needs to be some serious
thinking about getting a proper uk
energy market
going again and and not just kind of try
and plaster over the cracks with with
importing
importing energy in um from from our
neighbors so i think that's the sort of
long-term way of looking at it and then
shorter term i completely agree that
there needs to be better incentives for
for hgv drivers the average age of an
huv drivers 55 they're all retiring no
no more have been trained up during
lockdown i think a simple recruitment
drive would help um i
don't know
very few people seem to know very much
about becoming an hgb driver so that
could be part of it um but but there are
quite a few more things i think the
government could be doing both both in
the short term and the long term yeah at
the the metro inside the metro has a
pretty stark image of the uh bp tankers
all lined up at an oil terminal um
i think i heard a statistic today
jasmine that only one percent of hgv
drivers are women
i mean that doesn't necessarily surprise
me i mean i think you know olivia's
right in the sense that we don't really
know much about this sector it's long
hours it's pretty low pay it's quite
grueling it's quite demanding we now
know how important it is don't we
yeah definitely and i think it's one of
those things where you know we take it
for granted that we can go to the stores
and we can find whatever we want that we
can go to the petrol stations and we'll
be able to get our petrol at a decent
price and actually the past few weeks
have shown that actually you know the
supply chains and the very systems that
are put in place to make our lives
easier they're actually quite fragile
and if we don't have a proper investment
in you know in in workers for these
sectors and making sure that people are
paid correctly and making sure that
we've secured up our supply chains
actually the ripple effects can be felt
and i do think that this is going to be
a huge problem for the government
because this is bread and butter stuff
if you go into the supermarket and you
can't find what you want if you go to a
petrol station and you can't get what
you need you feel that instantly and it
doesn't really inspire confidence that
you've got a government that is
improving your quality of life and i
think it's very significant in the
context of leveling up this is a
government that's promised to you know
boost equality across the country
and that isn't really compatible with
rising with rising bills and shortages
olivia let's move to the other story
which is across that many of the front
pages and that is the story of sabina
nessa the teacher who was found dead
killed just a short distance from her
home the front of the metro uh with the
headline that a 38 year old man has been
held
this is a story just six months after
the death of sarah everard that has
prompted that debate over women's safety
yet again
and what has changed in that time
despite that outcry olivia six months
ago
what has changed what has been done
it feels like very little has been done
at all it was it was so odd after sarah
everard uh instant the way it turned
into some sort of strange uh
war with the police there was that vigil
and and it just instead of instead of
anyone sort of trying to
grab the grab the nettle it was just it
turned into a kind of clash between
women and the police which was
absolutely bizarre and so nothing seems
to have been done and now we're in the
same horrible situation again um she was
just out for a walk she actually lives
just down the road from me um and it's
it's a really scary horrible thought
uh and and i think it's going to it's
sort of been a little bit slow to slow
to build as a news story i think because
the police knew so little at the
beginning when it when the when the
details for the first measure it's
taking a while to come through but now
an arrest has been made i think it's
going to sort of fire up the public
imagination again and i think we're
going to see the same sort of outpouring
of anger as we saw six months ago
she was killed on the same day that her
majesty's inspectorate constabulary
released its report jasmine on the
epidemic of violence against women and
girls there is now a call for violence
against women to be prioritized in the
same way as as terrorism is do you feel
that that there are moves in that
direction
i mean certainly there is a growing
sense that you know more can be done on
this certainly when you know we heard
the tragic case of sarah everard there
was you know as libya was saying there
was a there's a real sense of anger and
a sense you know and a desire to sort of
change laws and to really act on this
issue but it sort of feels like the
progress has been pretty slow like i
remember a few months ago we were
talking about making socially a crime we
were talking about the government was
talking about
more money for street lighting to make
it brighter when women walk down the
road all these sort of incentives and it
doesn't really seem to have made a
difference in the past few months and i
do think you know it's all well and good
having tough rhetoric from the
government on this issue but i think
more needs to be done to make sure that
you know people and women in particular
feel as though you know when they're
walking home they can they're going to
be safe and they're not going to be
attacked and feel as though that when
they report these instances to the
police that actually it's going to be
handled in a sensitive and rigorous
manner because even you know we know
when it comes to things like sexual
assault or rapes you know when it comes
to looking at the legal system the the
system when it comes to convictions are
pretty low so there's a lot more that
can be done
we are going to turn to the telegraph
olivia now the front of the business
section of the telegraph
um covert killing letters said royal
mail so we sent fewer letters during the
pandemic apparently
yes we did i mean it's i'm not sure how
to what extent that it's a pandemic
effect or just that letters that are
sort of
slowly but surely dying out we've kind
of seen the royal mail become a packing
packaging service really um it deals in
packages far more than letters and it
hasn't quite got the hang of that yeah
obviously we saw lots of problems during
the pandemic of people complaining that
amazon would get their product to them
in less than 24 hours and yet royal mail
it took days and days and days so i
think royal mail is still kind of
catching up with this big shift that
we're seeing away from letters and and
towards packages um it's it's it seems
quite sad but
the the letters were on the on the
decline during the pandemic i think i
could have done with a few more letters
during lockdown
yeah i thought the same that perhaps we
might have had more time to communicate
with people but maybe we were all on on
zoom or skype with people and but
jasmine royal mail
shares were down at 120 pence 18 months
ago but given
the prominence of parcels the role it
has played with our online deliveries
particularly during the pandemic now
trading at four times that
yeah i mean i do think it is right in
the sense that you know we've seen
throughout the pandemic it has sort of
struggled and to keep up with demand but
effectively this is an organization that
is an institution that we all have come
to know and recognize and love and and
hopefully there is still a space for it
even among the the amazons and the tech
giants of the world and i do definitely
think that you know it's almost slightly
counter product counter intuitive
because you would have thought that
during the pandemic we would have been
writing letters furiously and you know
we would have been communicating in sort
of the maybe slightly more old-fashioned
ways but you know i think it's it's part
of a longer-term trend in in that
regards and perhaps lesser writing might
become sadly a thing of the past yeah
raw mail now mulling on a five day a
week
letter service dropping the saturday
letter drops but potentially a seven day
a week parcel delivery service
let's move to our last story and that is
also in the telegraph page one of the
telegraph uh olivia and this is about a
facebook executive uh what can you tell
us
yeah i thought was quite interesting so
it's a facebook executive who's had to
apologize
for making a comment that if someone
dies in a terrorist attack coordinated
on our tools then i'm not quite sure
what it's he said but it's something
along the lines that it's not facebook's
problem um and he said that in 2016
five five years ago and i think it's
quite interesting the way we're sort of
that was that was a sort of line that
quite a lot of these big tech uh execs
use you know that that we're we're a
we're a platform where people can do
what they want in our platform we're
just there to provide the technology to
let people communicate um but we've seen
over the last sort of five or six years
that argument kind of falling apart you
know we've got um people blaming
instagram for for for an increase in
child self-harm for example um and these
these big tech platforms are sort of
having to admit that they're not just
platforms to some extent they're
publishers and obviously that starts to
interfere um with their business model
once once you're once once you're saying
that that there is you know we as the
big tech company have have some sort of
responsibility for what's being posted
on our platforms then it's much much
much more difficult to to have this
model where there are millions of people
shouting out into the ether all the time
and you don't moderate it so i just
think it's quite an interesting shift
that we've seen um in not very many
years that that this facebook exec is
now having to apologize for that comment
made just five years ago okay uh olivia
and jasmine for now thank you very much
indeed